die nasa hat neue erkenntnisse über die
dunkle materie gewonnen ein ebola
impfstoff ist zu 100 prozent wirksam und
fast food als wissenschaftlich belegte
sportlernahrung was diese woche in der
welt der wissenschaft passiert ist
erfahrt ihr jetzt bei den clixoom topf 1
hallo christoph ist moment leider krank
und kann die heutige folge überhaupt
nicht aufnehmen
aber damit ihr nicht komplett ohne video
über die ostertage auskommen ist
übernehme ich das video heute und ich
denke mal christoph ist dann ab dienstag
wieder gesund also viel spaß einer
impfung zu 100 prozent erfolgreich
testen mit einem experimentellen ebola
impfstoff sind zu 100 prozent
erfolgreich verlaufen
alle probanden zeigten im anschluss an
eine prävention behandlung eine positive
immunreaktion ohne große nebenwirkungen
eine große gruppe von internationalen
wissenschaftlern berichten dass
insgesamt 200 personen aus den usa der
schweiz und deutschland so auf den
impfstoff reagierten dass die vor
zukünftigen infektionen der ebola solche
komplett geschützt sind
der impfstoff der aus einigen proteinen
des ebola virus innerhalb eines anderen
virus besteht sei soweit ungefährlich es
besteht also nicht die gefahr dass sich
daraus eine weitere ausbreitung
entwickelt allerdings wurden die
testpersonen nicht mit dem ebola erreger
selber konfrontiert die erkenntnisse wie
effektiv der wirtschaft tatsächlich ist
erlangten die wissenschaftler aus
studien mit primaten
daraus können sie schließen wie viele
antikörper benötigt werden um eine
infektion zu verhindern
einige der probanden entwickelten
würdigkeit oder erlitten muskelschmerzen
große komplikationen fielen allerdings
aus ist fastfood vielleicht besser als
fitness protein shakes proteinen fett
und kohlenhydrate diese drei komponenten
spielen besonders für sportler eine
große rolle
vor allem im fitness bereich soll eine
gut ausgewogene ernährung den
muskelaufbau vorantreiben
fast food ist in einem solchen
ernährungsplan strikt untersagt protein
shakes hingegen werden in massen
konsumiert michael kramer von der
universität in montana hat diese regel
genauer untersucht und kam zu dem
ergebnis dass fast food ähnliche
leistung hervorbringt wie eine fitness
ernährung
er fand heraus dass die testpersonen die
fast food konsumierten nach einem
training eine höhere glykogen
konzentration auf wiesen glykogen ist
ein wichtiger energielieferant für die
muskeln obwohl die studie sorgfältig
kontrolliert wurde sind die erkenntnisse
aufgrund der geringen anzahl der
versuchspersonen allerdings immer noch
mit vorsicht zu genießen
außerdem treffen sie möglicherweise
nicht auf weniger trainierte personen zu
dennoch zeigt die studie dass
gelegentliches fast food nicht so
schlecht für die fitness ist wie sein
ruf
denn der körper merkt da gar nicht woher
seine nährstoffe eigentlich kommen ein
simples kohlenhydrat bleibt ein simples
kohlenhydrat egal ob es über normales
essen oder eine spezielle sportler
ernährung aufgenommen wird
bunte farbenpracht im gelben meer wasser
bedeckt 71 unseres planeten und bewirkt
dass wir die ehre als blauen planeten
bezeichnung dabei nimmt das wasser weit
mehr farben an die aufnahmen von
satelliten zeigen lebende organismen und
andere materialien sorgen dafür dass
sich das meer blau grün weiß hellbraun
oder sogar braun färbt ein ort an dem
das farbenspiel der natur besonders gut
zu beobachten ist liegt im gelben meer
die braune färbung vor der chinesischen
küste ist durch schlamm entstanden der
sich mit dem wasser vermischt das ist
typisch für küsten bereichern
laut experten sind die geringe
wassertiefe gezeitenkräfte und starke
winde dafür verantwortlich die weiteren
verwirbelungen könnten durch
temperaturunterschiede im wasser
entstanden sein
im winter fließt ein eher warme wasser
strom in das gelbe meer
das verändert die oberflächentemperatur
des wassers und bringt es in bewegung
bisher ist es zwar noch nicht möglich
die einzelnen partikel und materialien
anhand von satellitenbildern zu
unterscheiden
in zukunft sollen aber weitere kleine
satelliten dazu beitragen
genau diesen prozess der ozeane
überwachung zu vereinfachen
die daten sollen in erster linie
informationen über den einfluss des
klimawandels auf die ozeane ökologie
liefern
wer ist die schönste im ganzen land
mit dieser frage haben sich forscher aus
großbritannien beschäftigt sie in ihrer
studie war es herauszufinden wie
testpersonen das perfekte also das
schönste gesicht definieren dabei wurde
das 90-60-90 schäden nicht
berücksichtigt die schönheits forscher
betrachteten nur die gesichter mit dem
blick auf die proportionen als
referenzgröße wurde dazu die breite des
gesichts auf höhe der augen gemessen das
ergebnis frauen bei denen der abstand
zwischen den augen 48 dieser
referenzkurs ausmacht wurden am
attraktivsten beurteilten
zudem waren eine schmale nase und volle
lippen die etwa so breit sind wie die
nase lang ist die spitzenreiter unter
den testpersonen
am besten kamen herzförmige gesichter
bei den probanden an
bei männern bevorzugten die testperson
vor allem braune haare und blaue augen
die perfekte kopfform ist den
ergebnissen zufolge ein oval
außerdem wird eine kantige männliche
kinder anziehen so die forscher
besonders wichtig ist es laut der studie
aber vor allem dass das gesicht
symmetrisch ist dunkle materie hubble
liefert weitere ergebnisse dunkle
materie wird nicht langsamer wenn sie
untereinander zusammenprall
das bedeutet auch dass sie weniger mit
sich selbst integriert wie bisher
angenommen
das haben astronomen mit hilfe von
beobachtungen des
hubble-weltraumteleskops und dem chandra
axway observer tory herausgefunden
die experten der us raumfahrtbehörde
nasa sehen die neuen erkenntnisse als
weitere annäherung an die mysteriöse
substanz aus der vermutlich einen
großteil unseres universums besteht da
dunkle materie weder reflektiert noch
licht empfängt oder sogar ausstrahlt
kann es nur indirekt beobachtet werden
das wird beispielsweise durch die
verzerrung des gravitationslinsen
effektes gemessen den sie verursacht um
mehr über die dunkle materie
herauszufinden und bestehende theorien
zu überprüfen untersuchen
wissenschaftler die materie ähnlich wie
experimente mit sichtbarer materie zum
beispiel wenn diese in ein anderes
objekt hinein kraft in diesem falle sind
die beobachteten kollidierenden objekte
galaxien cluster diese bestehen aus drei
hauptbestandteilen galaxien gaswolken
und eben dunkler materie wenn sie
kollidieren bremsen sich die gaswolken
gegenseitig ab die galaxien allerdings
sind schon wesentlich weniger davon
betroffen da die abstände zwischen den 1
ein stern viel viel größer sind auch die
dunkle materie wird nicht abgebremst das
bedeutet dass die dunkle materie nicht
mit den sichtbaren teilchen interagiert
und sie passiert auch andere dunkle
materie ohne eine wirkliche reaktion zu
zeigen
vor allem für die mathematischen und
physikalischen modellen der
wissenschaftler stellen die
beobachtungen jetzt eine erleichterung
dar denn durch jede neue erkenntnis wird
eine unbekannte variable in ihren
berechnungen
was meint ihr wie nachkommen wie der
dunkle materie in der zukunft oder sind
wir schon ganz nah dran diskutiert es
wie immer unten in den kommentaren mehr
zur dunklen materie gibt es in diesem
video und hier geht es noch zum blog
dort gibt es regelmäßig news rund um die
wissenschaft und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran